Yeah
It's a whole nother squad behind all of the action
so this scene is like
Widely known as one of the worst action scenes of all time break down one of your favorite fight scenes for us
This is my favorite shot that I got to do right here
Thanks to disco for sponsoring today's episode
If you guys want to find out how to get three months free of the best cloud storage interface money can buy stick around
Hey everybody, welcome to a very special episode. We're not talking about just stunts
We're not talking about just vfx today
We're talking about action design and we're talking about it with none other than Chris Cohen who is an action designer
It's basically his job to take the stuntmen in the choreography and make it look good on camera
So that requires a lot of intuition for camera motion cutting points angles as a whole other squad behind all of the action
So if you love action and you want to get a deeper understanding of it well
This is the episode for you. If you jump right in with Kingsman, let's do it
There's two units on the film
there's the main unit and they typically handle all of the dialogue all of the acting and then there's the second unit which does
All the action this was my first job ever getting to hold the camera
it was nerve-racking for me because I was working with the main unit director Matthew Vaughn to have
everyone there and they're like Chris go, i was like what
It was a tight fit
Yeah, how do you film in a car like this? the sfx department tore this cab apart
They shot with a arri alexa mini like it was stripped down completely because I was like, yeah
We can't do this stuff with a 50-pound camera
Right here to start the shot
They have they took out the roof and you're on a crane the crane would boom down follow the hand
Right here hold hold hold. That's Edie. And then right there, that's my buddy, Andy
And I can tell that that's him because he always makes that face
This is my favorite shot that I got to do right when he catches it with this toe, yeah
He did it himself? yeah he did that was him. Oh good for him
Is it all one shot with how many cuts that was all one shot?
Yeah, but they had like this mechanical arm underneath that swung and and spun at the same time
Brad had the detail that he wanted to see the toe - the second toe and see like the full body extension
Not only that the pressure was on to continue the shot from the face look up find the button then back down to the face
And then pull back and see full body when you're doing a lot of big action like this
You really want to keep some of the stuff especially your your in and out points either
Central or if like say if it's frame left
It's better to pick up the next shot starting with the central point being frame left
That way people don't have to try to find it, you know miss key moments
You can see like for the the old ball punch here that's going straight
Yes as we cut in you know
The fist is still centered
And that's such a high level of craft and I think that goes completely over a lot of filmmakers heads when they're doing action
Pulled out of that
How do you do that ? Tarrant was on a wire and they had him yanked through
and I had to
Get back because that wire he was coming out no matter what
There's something about your work that I think that's actually it's been a big influence on me always in your fight scene when the actor
choreograph to throw a right hook the other actors choreographed a block with his right hand and then
cameras choreographed to do canted angle twist pop out punch zoom,  right
So you have your own fight scene that you're doing with the camera while the other guys are doing their fight on top of it
Yeah, we joke and call the kam Chi kam gym
You have to have the you know the presence of mind to remember the choreo and remember the beats
And once you can you can just start dancing with them and telling cool stories within their movement
I love that this fight scene shows
little mini stories all these little problems and then need to be solved and they're solved in clever ways and it takes it to the
Next little problem that needs to be solved
In a clever way as long as you have the moments in the scene within the scene and you just have you know
choreo, in between to take you to the next moment each beat is
So much more emphasized
The diner sequence so you worked on this as well, right? Yes
This was a lot of running around especially when it starts the the long one shot sequence definitely inspired by the first movie. Oh
Man that is such a cool shot. Wait over these blends these matches. That's
And they show it Burger Time, all right tell us a little about this insanity that is a scene. Sure that right there
He's not holding anything
He's just holding two rope all the way up into his right hand and that's fully animated afterwards the light trail
That's a good touch on it too and all the ground is all padded
They'll come in and they'll put in foam mats to let them you know to hit
Colin Firth is I think a real Kingsman on and off camera like just a gentleman. He's the coolest dude ever
I'm surprised on how spry he is. Considering how old he is. Yeah, he gets it done
This this shot I'm holding a rig and the camera is inside of this sort of cage and someone is on a remote control
Who's able to control the roll Wow, so I'm just tracking that someone is rolling with
As you start behind the counter right and now you're on the other side of the counter
our department was able to remove certain sections of the counter and
Then VFX Department put them back in these camera moves. You're flying around all over the place
How are you doing that while keeping it somewhat smooth really that's just all hand held and that's from years of-
Because it looks like it's on a Steadicam Oh, excellent
It just goes from years of experience not having any equipment and trying
This was actually shot all long-grain they rebuilt the entire background in the air they got a face element of
Hedgerow, that's a stuntman. Yeah, that's all three our stuntman only. Those are all face replacements
Yeah, Wow, I can tell you proud of this scene because when we were watching it
Like you're you're in it reacting to it, and that's a really good sign
What was cool about working for Matthew Vaughn is that he told the Action Team he was like, don't hold back think
Outside of the box completely just go crazy if it's too crazy. We'll tone it back
But don't think you have to work within these sort of guidelines
Every product of genius is the product of enthusiasm so. Oh I like that. It's a good saying found it on a fortune cookie
Please consider subscribing to the channel. If you have not already. We're banging out good stuff all the time
You might not even know it but on the days that aren't the weekends. We also put out videos on the channel and they're good
What go out the back I have another car
This scene oh god, I remember this
Infuriated me this. Okay. So this scene is like widely known as one of the worst action scenes of all time
It's been ridiculed
It started the whole meme of like the shaky cam and shaky cam has its place
It does it does
But there's shots in this fight scene where the cameras clue you got to do shoulder and he's on a wide angle. It's
Okay
His attacks looks like the camera seems to almost move in the opposite direction of what you're trying to watch
Yeah, there's a random shot Madrid slags there in the middle. So let's have him me the guy and show their faces
How do you shoot this to keep a little bit of the style but make it a better like read more readable fight scene with
more emotions and more impact follow the attacks
One of the most important things is seeing what's actually happening
Like if someone's going for a kick don't show the shoulders
Way less cuts, let it breathe. Let your choreo breathe let the audience watch
You know what they're doing, you know if they're doing like three cuts for one punch like 1 2 3. Yeah
That's way too many
CG Matt Damon
Turn you turn the stove on you Jam a magazine in the toaster. You set it to extra crispy corn
It's the right when your magazines done and ready to eat the house will explode
So I have a quick request for you guys it's easy to find good action scenes
There's a lot of them out there
But it's really hard to find bad action scenes that are worth talking about and breaking down
so if you guys have a action scene that you think is just
Awful, that would be great. We would love to do it in some future video. So please leave a comment
So when I was watching solo this was the scene that definitely stood out to me and this is I
Didn't even know who had worked on this one either - it's just like like ah, this is good
There's some cool concepts going into this
So this was really cool to shoot also
very nerve-wracking the trains actually on a rig to do these Full Tilt's we are up in the air about
30-40 feet. I'm not a stunt guy
I'm not a heights guy to have me up there shooting
My favorite shot that I got to do this little stitch we go from Andy Lister Maisie stuntman again to
Woody Harrelson and the stitch happens right there
What's the trick for getting a good stitch
Just making sure that all parties repeat their motion the best way you do it a few times enough times
You're gonna get you'll get something that works
What was fun about the shoot too is that they had this system called inves this shot right here for instance
Through the camera I could see these storm riders
Riding around I could see the mountains you can see
Yeah certain
You know bins and the track I could see the the rest of the Train
It helped me frame what was going on and the actors are doing their best bike use to look there. They're just looking at blue
We have no idea what's going on
They have realistic
Masks for the stunt performer to wear this movie and Kingsman both had them. That is a mask Wow
On top of our stunt performer. That's crazy some Aria start
100%
And standing next to chewy on set
Is surreal like because you keep like he'll be standing there. Do you just sort of keep like I
Know that a lot of your inspiration is anime 100
Anime is insane the action design that's used in in anime has like changed me completely
Animes hand-drawn, you know every frame is labored over and you've brought that over to the world of live-action film
I love it break down one of your favorite fight scenes for us
Okay, if you guys are familiar with Naruto Shippuden, don't don't roast me
The Kakashi Obito fight
English and it's all silent with just the sound effects and they do this like really cool not back to when they were kids
I love how an animated action moments hang and pause differently than they would in reality
There's like a natural speed ramping to enemies. Yeah
Like that, you know like the blood suddenly
See how it causes for a little bit and then boom like you really build up to the shoot that's sick
And I love these shots like come on
Yeah, I've been waiting to try to do some stuff like that what I draw from is how they do moments
You know you go Coryell
pop pop pop pop pop to go into like something like this to draw their eye to something happening and people are like
You know, what's that? The next shot is typically a wide to reveal what that is
I feel like that's what keeps people interested when they don't know what's coming next and anime is really really good with that
You're taking your hand up doing some live action anime
I have this is I think the closest would come to seeing it happen right here
The most ripped high school student
Like oh my god, you're getting the beats you're getting the rhythms of like actual anime. I appreciated
This was 100 percent last minute
He comes over
who you guys have met in the
previous stuntman reacts and we stumble upon this idea to just try a version of my hero if you a high school was based in
Los Angeles
How do you get him to lift off the ground like that you're not using wires
No, he's just they are all just going for it and being to know such anime fans themselves
They sort of understand the body language
I have never seen somebody get the grass angle from anime before is it just like a little camera on a gimbal? Yeah
It's a tiny pocket. Camera Wow. It looks great
So with that shot is you okay. So how did you do this shot because it looks super cool basically
I'm just trying to repeat the same motion
Wait, wait, wait, everything else makes sense because it's like oh this is maybe a match cut or a jump cut
But this one what's kind of perfect except for if you find it there. Mmm. I didn't do rat Nate properly
Yeah, haha, because your eye is following the backpack and what ghee is doing. That's my sort of wit pan stitch right there
Hmm. I haven't had one comment. Call me
J's character I was like, we just have to make it look as seamless as possible. Oh
Did you just pull him the Zach King here? We just do it until you nail it
Yeah, it's yeah, it just comes down to having really good choreography that like has enough motion to keep your eye distracted
He almost did your infinite rolling shot
The fact that we have this tool that is the internet now, I mean
It's allowed all of us to wedge ourselves into this industry without asking this right
No, we're we're here. We're gonna make stuff end of the day
You're always making your content for an audience and now we get to just make it directly for you
It's not really anybody in between that gets to decide what happens. It's just we make it you watch it
And that's that the internet changed everything and we don't do an anime video together
You al a part three is out right now there's a something on the screen you can click it ending no watch
All right now and have your mind blown his YouTube channels Riven x3. I can also call an Instagram. It's the same thing Chris
I hope you continue to make awesome work. Thank you guys so much in our pleasure. Yeah, you bet
Okay, hey, it's your old pal Brandi O'Daniel here you see Jake sent me up because he said mr
Neko played some music for you a couple weeks ago
So if you'd oblige me, I'd like to play a little tune here on the mandolin
But first I got to tell you about today's sponsor
Disco, you see disco is basically like virtual heaven. Disco allows you to work on all of your files that you have in cloud storage
Seamlessly from your home computer and then it puts them right back there where it found them back on the cloud
So whether or not you use Google Drive or Dropbox or any of these other popular?
Platforms doesn't matter. You don't have to be constantly signing in just to access your files
It's real simple Disko links your cloud drives as if they were actual hard drives on your computer
Meaning you can easily move files back and forth all without taking up space the most important thing that it does for us around here
is it allows us work much more efficiently, which allows me to focus more on the music and
Just like a G chord. It makes me all happy inside. So if you're like us and you're working with multiple clients
Transferring large data sets back and forth across these different platforms boy
I got to tell you you get yourself disco and you'll be hotter than a Ford v8
So if you want to sign up for disco just go to patron dot me slash
Corridor and all the details will be right there for you
also
If you're interested in finding out how to get three months free click the link in the description below
Now on to that song I was telling y'all about
When you get blues
Don't hurry
Just get this go and go on to get your files
come right back home the country mile and you'll be right here sitting with your
Videos and photos and everything creative that you do